that's completely I'd like to welcome
you all the borders in clayton my name
is Georgie and I'm your field national
event specialist don't let that scare
you it's just what they write on my
business card and I think you're pretty
smart to show up here this evening I
have come to really adore this guy and I
never thought I would because economics
run away people like me happy people
like me made it all the way through
college never having to pick up a book
that said anything about numbers on it
and we all thought that economics meant
that adding and subtracting and
multiplying and square rooting and all
those scary things so I was surprised
when Pam our corporate sales
representative found a book that she
just adored and said you must read this
I went oh yeah sure and I put it on my
shelf she said no really I'd like him to
come to a signing and I'd like you to
read the book and tell you tell me what
you think so I read the book and I
passed it on to three other people and
all of us adore it and who knew that
economics has nothing to do with square
rooting and multiplying and dividing it
has to do with life currency who knew
it's so cool so I'm not going to take up
all of your time because now you know
I'm not the brightest person I'm just
the happiest person you're ever going to
meet who's found a book that I
absolutely adore by a wonderful man
named Russell Roberts who I know as an
NPR commentator I didn't even know he
was from our community and now for my
big important words I want to tell you
that he is a John am Olin senior fellow
the weed and bombs center on the economy
government and public policy at
Washington University and I present to
you my new friend Russell Roberts Thank
You Georgie
well I want to thank Georgie rock and
Pam McReynolds here at borders in
Clayton for putting together this
wonderful full event and having me here
which is it's a wonderful book store and
I always like coming here now the
invisible heart and economic romance is
one of those classic boy meets girls
stories but in this case the boys an
economist so it's kind of a handicap and
it evokes all the classic love stories
of the past involving economist's I
can't think of any either so it's really
you know boy meets girl girls disgusted
by boy girl reconsiders girl invites boy
to parents house for dinner boy gets
into a shouting match with girls brother
etc but whoever said the road to true
love whatever be smooth and Sam Gordon's
the boy and Laura silver is the girl he
teaches economics at the edwards school
which is an expensive and exclusive
private school in Washington DC and she
teaches English at the same school and
plans to go to law school in the book we
learned about how each of them view the
world Sam looks at it through the eyes
of an economist and Laura's a caring
Ralph Nader want to be in a parallel
plot a ruthless businessman Charles
crowd seems to embody all the negative
aspects of capitalism to Sam early
oversell the beauty of capitalism why is
Sam under the threat of dismissal can
Sam and Laura ever find true love get
economics actually be a little bit fun
so that's what the books about but what
it's really about is how we create a
world where human possibility can
flourish and what kind of world is that
so I ask yourself some of you have
children many of you have been children
before probably right you ever noticed
how willful children are that they like
to do their own thing and they want
their own way all the time they don't
want to do what you want they want to do
what they want one of the first words
the baby learns is no as in put the
Waterford crystal down no they're
extremely willful we understand that our
job as parents is to keep our kids from
doing whatever they want when they whine
we tell them to stop we don't respond to
the request when they blame others for
their problems we urge them to take
responsibility for their own actions
rather than blaming a sibling we don't
let them play in traffic we make them
sit in the car
see even when they scream we try to make
them eat their vegetables we try to
limit their intake of candy and we try
to explain why but we don't want our
kids to stay kids forever the whole idea
of being a parent is to prepare them for
the real world the world of adulthood
where no one is standing over them
telling them what they can do what they
can't do we're wining is a handicap
we're shifting blame is unproductive and
one way to define the difference between
a kid the grown-up is that parents take
responsibility for kids but grown-ups
take responsibility for themselves to be
an adult is to understand that the world
is risky and to act accordingly to be an
adult is to make choices and to deal
with the consequences to be an adult is
to take responsibility for your actions
we're children we don't like being told
what to do we really hate it as an adult
we don't like it when our boss bosses us
around we don't like it when our
siblings and as adults bosses around our
parents as adults we don't like it when
other people limit what we can do we
like to be free to choose what we want
to eat how we want to spend our time
where we want to work how we want to
play etc now Sam Gordon who's the star
of this book is one of those kind of
adults he wants to live in a world where
he takes responsibility for his actions
and he believes in extending that
freedom to others sounds pretty big
hearted but he also believes that the
way to make the world a better place is
to leave it alone which is quite syringe
by leaving it alone he means leaving it
alone he doesn't believe in safety
regulations he doesn't believe in
government welfare and his idea of
corporate responsibility is for
corporations to make a lot of money now
that sounds pretty heartless so could he
possibly be a nice guy Laura his fellow
English teacher at the edward school
isn't sure he thinks economics is
beautiful and she sometimes thinks he's
crazy or even cruel he believes that
economics helps us understand how the
world works and how to lead a life of
human possibility now sam's challenge in
this book is to convince laura and the
reader that the best way to make the
world a better place might be to leave
it alone and if Sam can convince laura
that capitalism as a heart
and maybe he can also convince her that
he does too now one point Sam's coming
out of the dry cleaners and he sprained
out his shirts and laura has just had
some some blouses dry clean and she
notices she talks to Sam and she notices
that woman's dry-cleaning seems to be a
little more expensive than men's dry
cleaning is that true would your
experience also it's what they say I
think it's true I don't dryclean a lot
of blouses but occasionally take my
wives in wifes I think I said wives my
wife's in uh and so a lot of people
suggest that this might be an example of
sexism and discrimination so Laura
starts complaining uppa this to Sam and
Sam has a slightly different explanation
and Sam has a whole different way of
really looking at the world and looking
at the world of business compared to
Laura and he admits that businesses are
pretty greedy like a lot of money but he
believes that competition is what keeps
businesses from hurting customers the
opportunity of a customer to go
somewhere else and so he he asked Laura
the following question he says would you
want your employees if you were ever
running a business to be ruthless or
loving Laura laughs at that because I
was ridiculous she's English teacher
she's never thought about running a
business he asked her you've ever stayed
in ritz-carlton and she says we have
once with my parents do you know the
Ritz Carlton's motto come on Sam how
would I know the Ritz Carlton's motto
sorry I use an example in class all the
time so I forget it's not on the tip of
everyone's tongue their motto is the
highest price and the greatest profit
you're kidding of course I'm kidding
that's their secret motto they use it
around the boardroom when they want to
make their plans to exploit consumers
and their their customers kidding again
their actual motto is ladies and
gentlemen serving ladies and gentlemen
pretty elegant for a motto yeah said Sam
it's not exactly an invitation to cut
corners to skimp on service here's
another example I happen to have my
wallet in your wallet I'm a weirdo or
haven't you been paying attention sam
says so he unfolds a piece of paper he
says actually I'm using it in this class
this week so I've got it with me it's an
old quote from an executive at Merck one
of the world's great pharmaceutical
companies here's what that executive
said
we try to remember that medicine is for
the patient we try never to forget that
medicine is for the people it's not for
the prophets the prophets follow and if
we remembered that they've never failed
to appear the better we've remembered
that the larger they been I isn't that
strange if you focus too much on the
bottom line you're less likely to
succeed successful companies companies
like Walmart Southwest Airlines fedex
Merck they bring quality products
extraordinary service and low prices to
the customer that's how they become
successful and they force their
competitors to try and match their
performance or as a little skeptical
about this she says you telling me that
the CEOs of those companies aren't
interested in making money no I think
they like making money as much as the
rest of us but greed isn't the key to
success what do you think would be a
better do a better job of serving the
customer a greedy selfish Pig who
pretends to care about others or a
genuinely nice person who treats
customers within sup with sincerity
that's absurd Sam nice people don't
finish first in business well Sam
doesn't agree with that so we argues
with some orange he argues back and he's
trying to show her how competition
drives people to act as if they cared
about others and to serve them with love
and affection and she finds he finally
hits on the following example which is a
little bit offbeat and bizarre he says
he says what do you eat for breakfast
what do you eat for breakfast what kind
of a question is that what do you for
bribery she said well usually a toasted
bagel where do you buy your bagels I'm a
little place around the corner why do
you want to know do you have any at home
right now say I'm asked well I think I'm
out actually I was planning to stop by
on the way home or maybe tomorrow
morning do you think you ought to call
him and let him know you're coming you
guys ever do that you're going off to
the bagel place you're gonna pick up
some bagels you say gee I better make a
reservation for my bagels hello I'm
gonna need a dozen bagels you never do
it not once never you just show up and
they're there is that not remarkable
since they say I'm thinking he says well
maybe they won't make it up the same if
you don't call them what are you talking
about Sam they always have enough you
ever wonder why that is sam asks you
ever go to sleep worrying that the
Baker's of the city won't make enough
bagels for tomorrow never why not why
not some mornings you only buy one
somewhere you buy a dozen somewhere
inches over brunch you throw three by
three dozen
isn't it amazing that all of a city
tomorrow there'll be plenty of bagels
you and your fellow bagel lovers don't
have to worry about it you not to make
reservations you have to call ahead
they're gonna be there isn't it
wonderous your bagel baker it isn't even
more incredibly your bagel maker depends
on thousands of people to help get those
bagels hot and fresh to you the people
who drive the trucks that bring in the
flour the people who work in the bagel
place the people who run the electricity
the people who provided the equipment
who's in charge of all that is their
bagels are in Washington DC or here in
st. Louis nope they just show up somehow
the bagels no one ever thinks about you
don't even think about it for a second
but here's the amazing thing the bagel
maker gets up at three thirty in the
morning to make sure your bagels are
fresh you wouldn't ask a friend to get
up for three thirty in the morning for
you would you but a stranger does it is
that not extraordinary not out of love
not out of love but out of self-interest
to make sure the business survives by
making sure the customer is content well
or is still not a little happy with this
she says I still think I'd rather be
served by someone who's motivated by
something other than self-interest sam
says look self-interested doesn't mean
greedy or selfish or hard-hearted the
Baker gets up at three-thirty the
morning might be a wonderful person he
may plan on amassing a fortune to make
sure he can endow a charity he may get
up early to help a child have an
operation maybe just want a nice home
for his family he may be overflowing
with love for all kinds of good causes
but the powerful thing about competition
in the marketplace is that your Baker
doesn't have to be overflowing with love
for you that's what's incredible and it
works so flawlessly you never even
notice it well Loras is okay from now on
I'll notice that she grants him that but
look Sam you're over you're exaggerating
how great the marketplace says they're
defective products they're dangerous
products they're slick advertising the
fools people there are some good CEOs
but there's some heartless ones who were
cruel and mean to their workers do a
lousy job she says I don't want to get
rid of the marketplace I just want to
make it better just a little bit better
sam says I think it's perfect perfect
you're joking right not really says Sam
you can have a perfect system with
imperfect outcomes I'm willing to
tolerate that degree of imperfection
when you Tampa with a complex system you
often make things worse that's why
regulation often hurts the people we're
trying to help it's like saying I think
the rain forest doesn't make enough
yellow flowers you can artificially
induce the rain for us to make more
yellow flowers but they may be scrawny
or or less healthy you'll have other
unseen effects and other types of
flowers and maybe a lizard or frauds
going to be affected because you change
the balance of color in the in the in
the flower population instead of trying
to control things that Sam I'd rather
rely on competition that the control is
decentralized dispersed as a way of
disciplining the imperfection so Laura
says the following she says look you
like the rain forest I like an English
garden you like a wild look I'm in favor
a little bit of pruning if you're going
to have a garden says Laura you need a
gardener or maybe a team of gardeners
and sam says well if you can tell me how
to make take mere mortals and make them
omniscient and incorruptible gardeners
I'm open to the suggestion and then go
on to talk about a little bit more about
why the dry cleaning is the way it is
and they they have a nice cup of coffee
and it turns out it's sort of an it's
sort of a comforting this conversation
for Laura to find out about the
economics of dry cleaning I hope that
gives you an idea of what the books
about there's a little bit of romance
there is a little bit suspense and
there's a scene I want to re-enact with
you if they'll play along a little bit
from another part of the book as Sams a
teacher he's a teacher of economics he's
got a class it's very offbeat class and
he likes to challenge his students to
think about things they haven't thought
about before and how the world works and
so he asked them the following question
and I'm going to ask you the same
question so while I'm describing I'd
like you to think about this here's the
question you're a dictator or king for a
day and you can pass any law you'd like
anything you want one law okay but the
law has to be realistic it can't be I
will ban greed or I will be in disease
or I will make lust illegal it has to be
an actual public policy a real piece of
legislation and so if you think about
you anything you only have one day only
get to pass one law
what's the single biggest problem in
America that I think needs fixing and
what this is the hard part we might not
agree on that right a great what do you
think the biggest problem facing America
is today pick some what do you think it
is poverty potholes pollution health
care right everybody has a different
issue that is their priority we all have
our own things we care about right now
now once you've done that once you pick
the one area that you think is the most
important now if you ask yourself what
piece of legislation what could I
possibly do to actually make a
difference that's a lot harder right so
if you say health care what might be a
solution to the health care problem what
would you suggest a national system of
healthcare other people would think oh
that's a disaster we need a totally
unnatural system much more choice much
more privatized poverty what should we
do for poverty
raise your level of education but other
people would say oh that's going to take
way too long it's easy to say that would
work how are we going to do that
wouldn't be much of a piece of
legislation raise our level of education
what do you mean you mean spent more
money some you say that's not going to
have any impact we need smaller class
size always some people say that won't
work there's all kinds of different
theories about how we would do all these
things apostles I think we're probably
pretty good at once guy to an argument
with someone who said that the reason
socialism is good is because in Sweden
they have no potholes I thought I doubt
it but anyway uh we have that's a
technological problem where we probably
have some idea of how to how to fix it
but we all have different ideas of what
might be a policy that would make a
difference and what law would make the
biggest impact on that problem that
we're trying to fix so Sam asked his
class that okay and they go through all
kinds of things somebody says we should
be we should have tougher laws against
drug use somebody says if you make drugs
legal right how could that be how could
two intelligent people come up with
exactly the opposite prescription but of
course you can and you make a pretty
good argument for it so you have all
kinds of different ideas of how to fix
the world so the students ask there it
is at each time one of the masks Sam
shoots him down he explains that oh well
look what would happen there'd be this
unintended consequence this would happen
as a result there'll be all kinds of
problems so the class goes on for a
while they argue back and forth and
finally the class demands that Sam
explain what his policy is what would he
do to make the world a better place and
he kind of teases him a little bit
because he doesn't really tell him what
he'd really do if he had his way but he
gives him a provocative idea said if I
could do whatever I wanted King for the
day the one thing I would do is I would
ban television ban television that's it
your king for the day you ban television
that's your big contribution to to
humankind in America's band television
and the easily well sure of course if we
be on television this bookstore would
have more people in it people will be
reading people be talkin spend more time
with their families sitting around the
table less distractions life would be
more real be fantastic that's kind of
interesting these are high school kids
are a little bit skeptical they kind of
like they like television explains to
them it's
got a lot of degrading things it turns
into a zombie it turns into a couch
potato your mind turns into mush buddy
that's his case but then he said
something a little bit surprising he
says well since the truth is if I could
be came for a day and even though if I
really believe that TV was the biggest
evil facing America and that this
banning of TV would make the biggest
single impact of any law he says I still
wouldn't ban it what do you mean said
you want to make the world a better
place you wouldn't ban it you just said
this is the single most important thing
you can be king for the day you wouldn't
ban and he says no and here's why he
tells them the following story says if i
offered you a billion dollars a year a
billion dollars a year for the rest of
your life no questions asked and the
only string attached is that every year
you have to spend every dollar would you
take it would you take it billion
dollars a year every year get to spend
it sounds kind of appealing but maybe
it's a little bit scary if you took it
would you be happy well of course the
students start arguing of course we'd be
happy would be thrilled says as well you
might be happy for a while imagine that
first day on the billion dollar a year
stipend little Lobster and caviar for
breakfast lunch in Paris after a brisk
trip on the Concorde maybe not the
Concorde maybe something safer with a
few hundred close personal friends why
not dinner in New York and the
presidential suite at the Plaza the
second day lobster and caviar for
breakfast again maybe a new restaurant
in Paris for lunch I mean for a change
of pace you'd fly in a chef from New
York to cook lunch for you and in the
background you have the New York
Philharmonic playing be kind of nice and
you're hosting it at the Guggenheim of
course but you've rented out and later
that night courtside seats with Spike
Lee at the Knicks game okay so maybe you
wouldn't choose the Philharmonic these
are high school kids but you get the
idea it'd be pretty amazing for a day
pretty extraordinary for a week well a
year would it get a little boring maybe
ten years once in said i'd like to try
yeah i know says sam it sounds appealing
but after 10 years of caviar for Brett
fist caviar tastes like corn flakes and
Sam Towson the following story says no
by the way I don't know where the
stories from I I've heard it before
you've probably heard it this is just my
version of it that's gone through my
memory and I have no idea what the real
story is or where it comes from but if
you know I'd like to know a man dies
finds himself on the bank of the most
beautiful trout stream in the world the
sky is a burning blue perfectly balanced
fly rod in his hand and formalize the
water a perfect trout stream its a mix
of rapid some slow pockets of water
where surely some big trout or lurking
all his life he'd wonder more time to
fish and he realized he's in heaven he
looks upstream and he sees a swirl that
the fish has arisen for an insect he
makes it exquisite cast of the exact
spot in an instant the water explodes is
an enormous fish surges of the surface
chunks of water flung from his side as
it strikes the fly the flash of power
and color caused the man to gasp in awe
and after a brief struggle he lands the
fish must weigh at least 12 pounds and
the colors are so vivid he releases the
fish turns back to the water and again
he sees a fish fries and again he makes
a perfect cast and again he lands
deficient it's another beautiful fish
it's a miracle the man falls on his
knees and gratitude to God but it's the
day wears on fish after fish after fish
breaking to the surface and answer to
his efforts a thought against the
flutter at the edge of his consciousness
he decides to deliberately make a poor
cast fish still rises still grabs the
fly still catches it starts yelling and
thrashing the water to spook the fish
doesn't matter every cast he catches a
fish he realizes it's not in heaven the
student says what's that have to do with
banning television he says banning
televisions against the rules of the
game not the rules are a game in here
that we're playing in the class but my
rules of the game for the good life the
good life is real it's full of ups and
downs success and failure coming up out
of the valleys makes the view from the
peaks exhilarating catching a fish on
every cast is in heaven having a billion
dollars is boring banning television
doesn't bring a
closer to the good life it doesn't
really transform the world it papers
over what is wrong it makes you think
you've solved the problem which is a
dangerous delusion why do you think the
stuff on television so degrading because
people like it why do people watch for
four hours a night and fall asleep at
the clicker because they don't have
anything better to do banning television
doesn't change that even if it could
what right do I have to make a
dysfunctional family talk among
themselves more often what right do I
have to force parents to spend more time
with their kids even if I had that right
why would you think that using that
right and treating adults like children
and taking away the candy of television
is the right way to transform the world
I'm proud of not having a television
Sam's told to me doesn't have one it's a
triumph I'll be at a minor one over my
baser nature isn't that what life's all
about coming to know yourself and
finding a way to do what's right what's
the good of having the government do it
for you through a law that reduces your
choices that's not life any more than if
we change the rules of the game and
consider the world where the government
could end anger or jealousy or greed or
lust or violence life in that world
would be no life at all and that's
really Sam's view of the whole world
that's Sam's view of public policy that
economics which illuminates that those
choices that the world around us is full
of risk and uncertainty and that that
world is worth living in when human
beings have the choices face the choices
they have to make in that world which is
the real world that's the world Sam
wants to live in I'm going to stop here
take any questions any thoughts any
alternative speeches yeah
is there a certain romanticism to sams
view of the world I'm thinking for
instance of nuclear power and it's
another environmental issue I don't know
if in the history of nuclear power if it
was something that was market driven or
if it was heavily subsidized and if it
would have come about under a truly free
market system because I think there
seems to be an optimism among free
market people that we will find new
sources of energy as as our current
sources of energy get depleted and the
price goes up then we'll be forced to to
have other other sources of power that
will become more more economical but I
when I think of nuclear power it seems
to me there's one where this is great
source of cheap energy relatively
speaking we have this incredible cost of
trying to figure out what to do with the
with the waist right we still in figured
it out all right so there's this this
balance of you when you look at that
history I just wonder you know are we
being a little bit too optimistic about
our people like stamping that are
optimistic about how will be able to
solve how the market will be able to
solve this kind of problems right I
think I think Sam maybe Sam's optimism
is misplaced probably rely on like the
state of California to solve the
problems cuz we can see they're doing
such a good job now sorry about that you
make a good point sometimes you can be
overly optimistic the nuclear power
example is a particular technology that
has particularly tricky piece of
application which is this waste problem
throughout most of world history we've
turned from existing source of energy to
new sources without that kind of problem
usually with wonderful effects in the
case nuclear energy happens be case
where the effects aren't so great do you
think about it in the early part of the
20th century in the late part of the
19th century the main source of energy
was wood and people were devastating
large tracts of forestry and in timber
to keep to keep warm and a huge industry
was devoted to getting that would to the
customer etc upstate New York was
decimated during the early part of the
20th century late part of the 19th
century to keep New York City warm
because that's where all the people were
thank God that is it necessary anymore
we have other forms of energy so we have
nice for
in the Adirondacks and other places that
have grown back and New York now has
more trees than it had a hundred years
ago which is you know stunningly weird
if you look at through most of of energy
policy you'll see that forms of energy
that were commonly used have been
abandoned as they got scarce or and got
too expensive whether that'll happen
forever maybe a matter of optimism the
offensive is based on the human on human
creativity that we've always been able
to find new sources that were safe now
maybe this will be an exception I don't
think so it may be that nuclear energy
looks like a solution because it has
been artificially subsidized I don't
know enough about it i dunno an example
that it's often the case the things that
that look good like capitalism often are
examples of subsidies a really bad
policy an example of us are talking
about trees is timber harvesting in the
National Forest is a disaster and it is
only done because the government
subsidizes the roads to get in there if
the companies that harvested that timber
had to do it by paying their own way
they wouldn't do it cuz the wood that
they're harvesting is crummy it's lousy
it's so profitable because there have to
pay the cost of getting in there they
should pay the cost of getting in there
and those first would be left alone and
that shows that's what I think we should
do so you can't look at any single
particular outcome and say I'll see you
know this is destructive you have to
look carefully and see whether it's
artificially being encouraged by a
subsidy case nukes energy may be the
case that may that may be true also yeah
oh how it saves girlfriend you
California Kurt energy woes well they're
not all I'm not sure I can call her
Sam's girlfriend but they do have some
romantic moments I just want to if the
books called the invisible heart an
economic romance the there is some
romance but I don't want to overstate it
it can be read at the beach but i'm not
sure i call it beach reading it's you
know it's only 250 pages but the romance
is a little thin for a typical romance
let's be honest but Sam's friend Laura
Laura would probably be in favor of
price caps on energies a lot of people
are suggesting out for wholesale energy
prices but what's great about America is
that we live in a time where there's
tremendous economic illiteracy
right the average American knows nothing
about I don't want to say nothing about
economics that's not surprising but
nothing about the history of our
economic life most people don't
understand what our standard of living
was a hundred years ago 50 years ago 30
years ago they don't know anything about
the history of price controls but that
having been said they understand that
there's no free lunch so when they look
at these proposals even the politicians
in California understand and the
consumers in California understand even
though they've never run a power company
that when you put a price cap on
something you might be paying a price
that's not so obvious that there's are
in dirt there might be some indirect
costs and I think people understand the
case of California that if we cap energy
prices now that future discovery is
going to be smaller just as most people
understand that if we cap pharmaceutical
truck prices drug prices that that's
good for today because people have lower
costs medicine we're going to we may pay
a high price in the future because there
will be less innovation so that's
actually a very high level of economic
understanding to understand the price
controls have costs doesn't mean you
should still be whether you should does
is the fact that price controls have
cost doesn't mean you should
automatically be against them right but
you should be aware of the costs when
you advocate them that's what's
important for an economist that's what
we we hope people understand how the
world works so most people are not blind
or looking at the world through
rose-colored glasses and assuming well
we'll put on price controls I'll be
cheap energy Thomas soul is a great
example he says he's got a new book out
called basic economics a nice book he
says you know some people think that the
reason that they can't have beachfront
property is because the price is high it
seems pretty reasonable right reason you
don't own a lot of beachfront property
is it's expensive but that's not the
real reason most of us don't own
beachfront property there a reason most
of us don't own beach front property is
there isn't enough to go around there's
a limited amount of it the high price is
the effect it's not the cause of why we
don't have it so understanding that the
roller price is a very high level I
think most people have some
understanding of price controls have
costs so in the case of the California
crisis and other crises when we might
face in the future I understand it's not
free keeping the price low is attractive
but it has cost and that's pretty good
that's
amazing yeah go back to romance romance
yeah okay good but basically I'm
understanding that Sam is getting a sort
of you said the star the hero of the
book let's say and laura's is the love
interest well now it's a little thin I
wouldn't Laura Laura is his intellectual
protagonist right that they bat they
argue back and forth she wants to say
here's what's interesting they both want
to save the world right Sam wants to
save the world by leaving it alone which
is bizarre laura wants to save the world
by fixing it right tightening it up
loosening this and tightening this over
here and making it better and now sam's
viewpoint of leaving it alone seems
indefensible right so what he's trying
to do in the book is to show Laura that
even though he thinks leave it alone
he's actually a pretty nice guy but
leaving it alone might actually lead to
a world of more human possibility of
more flourishing of creativity of a
better world for the next generation
which is a tough sell but he tries the
best he can that's getting it yeah terms
of the relationship yeah okay or if
there is a there is a relationship yes
yes I'll admit it yes in most
relationships both people are
transformed a bit uh-huh I'm just
wondering how she transformed Sam well
it's funny you mention that uh Sam's a
bit of a narrow guy okay because he
really only loves one thing besides
Laura we hope he loves economics and
economics although I think it's a
glorious thing we all understand it it's
really actually a very small part right
among the condoms it's the whole world
is everything and it's not just money
it's choices you make about who to marry
it's it's how many children to have
that's an economic decision not just in
terms of how much money they cost but
how you're going to devote time and all
these issues those are all economic
decisions in an economist mind comes a
little bit weird right a little bit
crazy so he's very narrow he only knows
about one thing and it's economics now
Laura someone interested in economics a
little interested in getting a little
more educated Laura's amar is a broader
person right and what she's able to show
Sam that helps Sam become a better
person among other things as poetry so
for example in Laura's first class of
the year
she's teaching English literature and
she asked the class she gives them a
line by words worth getting and spending
we lay waste our powers getting and
spending we lay waste our power seems to
be a total attack on Sam's view of the
world which is much more commercial much
more economic things business is
basically good so how is that Sam going
to be open to that she and one Scene
reads him Ulysses the poem by Tennyson
and he really likes the last line which
is to strive to seek to find and not to
yield and that in some ways embodies his
view of the world so Sam learns a little
bit from Laurie learns a little bit of
poetry starts brushing up a little bit
you know starts reading of getting a few
anthologies you know trying to see the
other side she never reads in economics
though as far as I can tell she gets
plenty from him so she's you know that's
her full dose but he doesn't get enough
poetry from her so he branches out on
the side and reads a little bit so that
that's true question you discuss at all
the way to San discuss the dot-coms a
little bit he does use the internet is
an example of an unsung what
unconstrained system in the early days
of the internet we're now in the
advanced stages right it's almost over
the internet you know we went it's like
I missed it the internet was something
that was unregulated many ways and the
people who are passionate about the
internet that's the thing they like the
best about it right they love that no
one's in charge of it no one decides the
only thing is I there are some property
rights there is some regulation there's
certain rules and regulations about how
you have to play on the game and how the
your URL your addresses are defined but
basically Sam sees that as a metaphor
for the whole economy at one point
because the internet know there's all
these problems on the internet that
people want to fix privacy money how do
we do ecommerce pornography how do we
keep children away from things that are
inappropriate and Sam's attitude is
basically leave it alone people will
have an incentive if these are problems
that people really care about people
have an incentive to fix them and I
think that's true to some extent right
there are a lot of problems of the
internet that we've been able to fix
could we have done better if someone had
been in shock
trivet perhaps but Sam thinks not Sam
likes the world Sam likes the world
where order is created by the individual
decisions of the thousands of people out
making their own decisions about what's
best for them rather than a czar or a
centralized federal organization trying
to side what's best so the Internet's an
example where a pretty cool place with
no one in charge it's pretty amazing did
you have another issue that was
interesting to you that you wanted to
howdy howdy approach fishing photos it's
an interesting example question was how
would Sam feel about fishing quotas it's
a classic example in economics of a van
unknown good fish population here's an
amazing thing the Alaska herring
population okay guess how long the
fishing season is for herring in Alaska
it's regulated okay there's a certain
amount of time you can catch her in
certain season right and the reason
there's a season it's not open all the
time you can't kill a herring on any day
you want right we regulate it why
because we understand if we let people
catch any fish they want anytime they
want since no one owns the ocean if you
catch a fish what's your incentive to
throw it back if it's not big enough
zero cuz you throw it back who's gonna
catch it not you so kick any fish right
catch everything you want to kill some
kill some dolphin who cares they're not
yours right it's a horrible attitude but
that's what of course some fishermen do
that's an example of where the lack of
property rights the lack of ownership
encourages antisocial destructive
behavior so how do we regulate that well
the way we regulate it most fishing
examples is we have a season to try to
limit the destruction and that way we
make sure that the even though no one
has a direct interest in letting the
fish grow and and reach a nice healthy
population they'll be restrained from
abusing it by the act of the season so I
guess along the atlantic herring season
is take a guess a week good guess
anybody else want to guess 30 days to
months it's eight
minutes they're all in one place if they
had it longer than 18 minutes they could
wipe out the whole thing so a horn goes
off and of course before the horn goes
off everybody is just you know jockeying
and jostling for position a horn goes
off these fish the entire catch of the
year is caught in 18 minutes because so
many of them in one place now that's a
very primitive somewhat effective but
primitive way to solve the problem what
some economists have suggested is giving
people ownership basically giving them a
license to catch a certain number of
herring now you got to enforce that
right hearings a bad example because
they're all in this one place I think
about most fisheries most public
resources water there's another strange
when you'd never think about and that's
highways st. Louis doesn't have the
worst highway problem in the world
people and st. Louis think we do but
that's because they never those are
people who've never lived in Los Angeles
or Washington DC or Boston or New York
but if you if you lived in Los Angeles's
I have basically you know the highways
are like a parking lot how do you that's
very inefficient why is that why is it
so inefficient the answer is because if
you enter into the highway zero cost
direct costs there's a time cost but you
don't pay anything to get on the highway
and so when you get on you don't take
into account the fact that you're
slowing down everybody behind you so too
many people get on and you look at how
we try to fix that how do we try to fix
it we build Subways bus systems never
has any impact on congestion it's a
stunning thing stunning thing and the
reason is it has a short-run impact but
eventually the roads just fill up again
until people people move in from further
away once you get the look at the metro
link or the metro or the subway and so
the impacts respond it's very much like
a fishery that seems like a weird
analogy but it's the same point just
like too many people get on the highway
if no one owns the highway too many
people fish out of the out of the waters
if no one owns the fish so there are all
kinds of primitive ways that we regulate
that but someone suggested we should
license it give out basically would be a
permit to let you fish or enter the road
etc and then let people trade them so
the people who value them the most would
be the people who use them well this
amount
peeling things about that for poor
people right so maybe you'd have to
subsidize that or give some of them away
turns out sometimes it wouldn't always
benefit people if you did it that way
but that's the way most economists try
to fix those kind of problems try to
create a property right so that people
have an incentive to use it more wisely
and that's the way you can Amish usually
looks at it yeah how would stamp you be
the shipping government spending in work
within decades from capital expenditures
to personal consumption when you say
capital expenditures the personal
consumption on the part of whom on the
part of government or individuals
personal consumption expenditures such
as
but the world where's his transfers of
money directly to individuals rather
than building things and well you know
it's kind of funny when I was younger I
used to talk about the importance of
private roads okay we just talked about
how roads aren't owned and that's that's
a problem in American it's America's
past there were there were private roads
toll roads Turnpike's those were all
private they weren't built by the
government they were built by
individuals when I suggested you know we
should have private roads he will say
private roads we had private roads
everybody would have a road leading
right up to their house I said I'll like
now huh that's all we have now right
everyone would build roads anywhere we
can write why hmm no wonder why because
everyone needs to go someplace maybe
there'd be a wiser way to get people
from point A to point B then everyone
getting over right up to their little
house maybe to have a road up to an area
who knows what the market would come up
with but when the government does it and
the government takes money from
construction people lots of roads is
always going to be the best solution
more roads wider roads all right we have
congestion problems what's the solution
wider roads let's widen the roads does
it ever make a difference never never
does a lot more people to get on the
roads with the same level of of time
misery that's true but it doesn't solve
the problem only way to solve the
problem is to institute some kind of
control some kind of property right some
kind of restraint on access some kind of
price other than time so I'm not
particularly depressed that we're
spending less on roads think we painting
a plenty of roads and just seems like we
have lots of roads in America like tons
of them same thing you can talk about
private money do we need government to
issue money well that's the world we've
always lived in we never thought twice
about it what if we have private money
and some people say well be a private
money the government the private people
the people who issue it would have an
incentive to print a lot of it and take
advantage of the users yeah just like to
do every government does in the history
of mankind in fact we're in an
extraordinary time and economic policy
we don't again we don't appreciate it we
live in an amazing time if you look at
at the US business cycle we off the
track here wat but who cares if you look
at the US business cycle over the last
hundred years the first 50 years look
like this meaning lots of big swings up
and down in the in the
the economy that's the first 50 years of
the center of the 20th century the last
50 years little swings what changed and
the simple answer is we figured out the
monetary policy and the amount of money
in the economy has a huge impact but we
didn't figure it out Milton Friedman
figured out which is an amazing thing
here's a one person it's one of the rare
cases where an academic made a
difference besides teaching people right
he actually believed that the money
supply was important you think well of
course it's important he was mocked
laughed at despised he could have gone
nuts probably did who knows it seems
like a pretty well-balanced guy but he
somehow stood up to the intellectual
humiliation of being alone and said no i
think i think it's the money Sky's
important and now nobody doubts it and
so central banks are much better able to
control the money supply actually better
to control the money supply but they
know that's what they're supposed to be
trying to do and as a result we have a
much smoother business cycle than we
used to have which is a wonderful thing
so the question would be human history
up to the last before the last 50 years
was full of disastrous moments where
government abused its power of the purse
to print money out of control to pay for
things the government wanted to pay for
the people didn't want and caused in all
kinds of inflation that's that's the
common history so oftentimes the private
solution could could be better yeah
cost-benefit military's
cost-benefit of military spending well
Sam didn't really deal with defense
issues Sam would probably believe that
defense is an example or government
spending is is probably a good idea but
just like the roads people have a
personal stake in the level of military
spending tend to advocate more ambitious
plans and so as a result sometimes we
get more than we might really want
because the political process responds
to that kind of pressure so he'd
probably say it's it's a good idea to
have defense but he probably says
probably have a little more than we
really want to have because the
political pressure of the contractors so
that that's not uncommon farm subsidies
I think Sam would be against those we're
almost out of time we last last take one
more question with this farm subsidies
um farm stuff is your funny thing we
romanticize the farm in America uh-uh
and we justify farm subsidies it for the
family farmer but must have got a very
wealthy corporate farmers so I think the
agriculture mark will work better if we
just left it alone I think Sam probably
feels the same way why were eight why
were why we who have no personal stake
in it believe that somehow we wouldn't
get food if farmers weren't subsidizes
is a strange thing to me but people feel
that way and I think the farmers have
encouraged us to fill out which is a
shame last question given that lawyers
don't play a large role in this book so
you're probably not going to compete
with John Grisham jetty the airplane
reading market yeah did you write the
book for who did I write the book for um
lawyers play small role the book as
Laura wants to be a lawyer and and and
believes that that's a very good way to
salt to solve the problems of the world
and sam tries gear to think twice about
it and they get into an ice storm a
argument at one point but I really wrote
the book for the for the average person
a normal human being not an economist
who wanted to understand a little bit of
how the world works and how a world view
that is based on economic freedom might
lead to the flourishing of human
possibility and America move in that
direction that it might be a good thing
would an R in like this book now part of
it part of it she wouldn't like and ran
wrote a book called the virtue of
selfishness and Sam believes very deeply
that selfishness is a is a self-interest
is good but selfishness is not so good
and he has is a very lengthy discussion
of the importance of charity the
importance of helping others how that
giving of charity transforms not just
the the recipient but the donor and so
he's not a hardcore iron randiyan at all
Murray I think Murray does like it yeah
he did what he didn't know either thanks
folks thanks for coming more books to
write for us we're gonna make